i need to throw away this piece of paper
and i can't move my body on it jakey
it's showtime here we go
i love this we're like batman and alfred
would rather be alfred than robin he has
access to the batcave plus he gets to
drive all batman's girlfriend's home and
dish doy
these college kids i used to wear long
sleeve t-shirts on my short sleeved
t-shirts wait a minute it's still good
hang on stop it oh no we forgot his
phone he's gonna turn around and see us
come on
sorry sorry hey guys what's up you want
to join our acapella jam circle oh no
are you guys harry potter fans i do not
like where this is going three four
won't you
come visit hogwarts
i'll be alone
[Laughter]
that's why
[Music]
so
you still annoyed yes you can't keep
saying mischief managed after we
finished sex it's what harry potter says
when he needs to clear the marauder's
map obviously i know that but i would
prefer to keep wizard turns out of our
sex life but what we're doing is magical
we're making a baby
oh what are the states and don't say
money because i know you're in debt if
you really knew anything about me you
would have said crushing debt and i'll
bet whatever cause there's no way i'm
losing what about your car oh
that thing is a date magnet i mean how
many girls have you made out with in
that car six well i'm gonna win so sure
let's bet the car oh
no
no jakey no that car is your superpower
thor would never wager's hammer neil
patrick harris would never wager a show
and ship losing that car will be the
worst in the world for you blade runner
tron ugh fievel goes west yes sir love
that little mouse his journey the story
of america i could not agree more rival
papa five-o
[Music]
hey
slowly back up there's a door behind us
we just have to get outside and call the
nine-nine
they're stealing the exits oh my god
it's real life die hard
i mean
oh no crime
all right let's see what we're dealing
with
i'll call you
klaus
you will be gutter with the little dots
over the u
you're good
hey matt are you in position i'm here
oh great the bad guy's name is matt
you're a cop
i hate cops
they gave me this
nice finally a good bad guy this dude
gets it now i'm gonna kill you okay you
took it a little too far maybe scale it
back skosh all set down here
okay start loading out i just have one
piece of business to take care of you
know killing a man is not as easy as it
sounds
i've killed 10 men and that's such a
nice round number when you agree i mean
imagine i've killed 11 people it just
sounds so
cumbersome
kayak other buckets
boyle you did it and you completely
botched the catchphrase i'm pretty sure
it was right no but you did great for
the last time the best cop movies in
order training day lethal weapon and
fargo end of discussion wrong die hard
is the best cop movie of all time one
cop heroically saving the day while
everyone else stands around and watches
it's the story of my life i like turner
and hooch tom hanks reluctant friendship
with a dog
that hits me where i live no
robocop it's got everything i like
gratuitous violence
oh i thought you were listing things i
was i'm done okay let's talk bad boys
that's the perfect cop movie mr smith
looking fine a hot cup of tea leone come
on
francois truffles breathless
what terry likes foreign films
okay
there is a correct answer to this
question though so gather round for the
greatest cop film of all time please
refrain from texting during our
presentation
all right so there's hitchcock and
there's an old hooker
come on guys that happened four years
ago that's the best part she comes back
takes the wallet and here she goes oh
but which of those relationships made
you happiest before it ended
my marriage
vivian yeah because you connect with
them emotionally something we did not do
because i'm a higher level of being like
her from the movie her
clear you've got to be in here somewhere
clear
i love this tux on gun out i feel like
james bond and you are my mysterious
femme fatale that i've been partnered
with maxi pads maxi pads i don't know i
didn't want to make the name too sexual
in my panicked look i'm so sorry but i
don't think there's room for a third
person on this case jake we should work
it solo well hang on now boy let's not
be hasty i mean stevie's been tracking
ozeroff longer than we have and three
heads are better than two he's a crowd
everybody knows that well what about in
the lion king hmm when jamon and per boy
become friends with steamboat that's not
the names it's simba timon and pumbaa
but i appreciate you trying it really is
a perfect analogy
all right listen up
what you're about to see is highly
disturbing but please no comments this
man is in pain so above all else be kind
good morning boyle
let's just get it out there
vivian broke up with me last night
i'm sorry chuckle bunny
charles wait yes
your food dehydrator
oh god
it's official
wedding's off
and this is what i'm like now
life is a pit excuse me i don't
understand did you already have a matrix
get up at home for some reason you know
what screw this we don't need a task
force to work the case all we have to do
is solve it before booth is done with
his interviews in two days that's
impossible you know i hate the word
impossible unless it's immediately
followed by the words ghost and protocol
i brought my dvd collection do you like
nic cage movies i don't know who that is
only the greatest and most compelling
actor of all time what are his movies
like describe them okay well one of them
is the fbi has developed face swapping
technology not interested there's a
whole plane full of convicts no on the
back of the original declaration of
independence there's a hidden treasure
map stop but that's the smartest one i
uh brought you your box of ddes huh
thank you
oh forgot about this one we never
watched captain corelli's mandolin
what the hell did you just say captain
crowley's mandolin say that to my face
captain girl's panel there was a movie
about a mandolin and you kept it from me
for two months well i didn't think it
was any good it's just some period piece
set in grease oh my gosh based on some
dumb book
terribly sorry it has been a very trying
time yeah next thing you're gonna say
you wish we would watch leaving las
vegas a dark ponderous reflection on
alcoholism that earned cages oscar ah
what i told you the guys got ranged i am
having dinner with my parents okay liar
what restaurant you going to i don't
know some italian place oh italian makes
sense pinocchio
he's a liar too and italian
i overexplained it i guess that's your
new best friend now santiago
emphasis on iago backstabber i'm
surprised you read othello what the
hell's othello i'm calling you the
parrot from aladdin what is going on
with you two come on boyle not this
again you gotta admit there's a spark
how many times do i have to say it she's
like a sister that's what luke said
about leia hey luke didn't know no one
knew santiago and i will be performing
the steerage jig from the film titanic
which we have prepared for in no way
shape or form romantic now embarrassing
milady
you're the smitty hate your guts channel
that passion into the dance peralta
skully tag in okay keep spinning
yes
so
how are we gonna do it here's everything
you need to know
it's plank it's a metaphor you get
nothing you lose good day sir
we got the letter well done
now get me madeline and a bucket of
water
it's time to melt a witch
lunch
hello raymond you're looking old and
sickly so nice of you to greet us
madeline i thought surely you'd still be
crushed under that house in munchkin
land sticks and stones raymond
describing your breakfast
you